this is where we will live only in  America da-ad tax after you see the  ticket place only in America can such a  perfect game exist face board hamburgers  cheeseburgers bacon chili cheeseburger  everything on top of everything economy  value in how we're happy I'm going to  America so I'm gonna be your Hollywood  star  again the PWG now you to wear a bit  under uganda i am looking for instinct  [Music]  [Applause]  you know try this is where we will live  you see the rock right  you see rock I see an opportunity we'd  only be gone a short time  everyone here is said that's everywhere  in it Mally's here can give you all you  can eat shrimp  [Music]  this is life we don't always get or not  a shot you always thinking of going to  move when we haven't left the ground  [Music]  yes I'm going to take you to the moon  [Music]  you